will donald trump give clemency to ross
ulbricht who's serving a life sentence
without parole for founding and
operating the black market e-commerce
platform called the silk road
please mr president consider my son ross
ulbricht
please give him a second chance he won't
let you down
the case for commuting ulbrick's
sentence is simple he never directly
harmed anyone and his sentence was
wildly disproportionate to the severity
of the crimes for which he was convicted
life sentence without parole is
shockingly extreme
the bluntness by which the judge
communicated why she was
pronouncing this sentence would took
everyone really by surprise
at that fateful hearing in 2015 u.s
district judge
catherine forrest told the courtroom
that she had decided to go well beyond
the mandatory minimum
of 10 years because ulbricht had taken a
philosophical stand
against drug prohibition the silk roads
creator thought that he was
better than the laws of this country
this is deeply troubling
terribly misguided and very dangerous
the silk road's stated purpose she said
was to be beyond the law which is
exactly right
and why prohibitionists should have
instead tried to learn something from
albrecht's creation
america's public enemy number one in the
united states
is drug abuse in order to fight and
defeat this enemy
it is necessary to wage a new
all-out offensive what judge forrest
failed to see
is that what's actually troubling and
misguided is the u.s war on drugs which
has cost the public more than a trillion
dollars
fueled decades of crime and violence and
stolen life years
away from millions of americans ulbrics
set out to disrupt the drug war by
moving sales to an online
marketplace impervious to government
interference where consenting adults
could buy and sell anything of their
choosing
he aimed to abolish the use of coercion
and aggression against mankind according
to his old linkedin profile and
create an economic simulation to give
people
a first-hand experience of what it would
be like to live in a world without the
systemic use of force
his arguments are incredibly uh
relatable
you know he he argues you know very
succinctly
okay why is it that people are thrown in
jail for buying weed or
magic mushrooms when it comes to that i
think i completely
agree with ross and his arguments and
his ideas
where i i started to have a really hard
time was with the idea
of selling of things like heroin and
fentanyl vanity fair's nick bilton
argues that the silk road caused
irreparable harm to others
citing the six people who allegedly died
from drugs they had purchased on the
silk road
including a teenager in australia who
had an adverse reaction to a
hallucinogen
and had jumped out of a hotel window
those deaths were tragic and
heartbreaking
and jurors were right to be moved but
the real culprit is the drug war itself
because that's what drove the narcotics
trade underground in the first place
that's why there are no reputable brands
or quality control in heroin
lsd or mdma meaning users have no choice
but to take dealers at their word
the silk road was an albeit imperfect
attempt to correct for the lack of
information in drug markets which is why
on net it probably saved lives a study
in the international journal of drug
policy found that users flocked to the
silk road out of concern for
street drug quality and personal safety
and vendor selection appeared to be
based on trust
speed of transaction stealth modes and
quality of product
several users on the site's forums
regularly answered questions about drug
safety
and what to do in the case of an
overdose the silk road made
buying drugs too easy according to a
mother whose son
struggled with addiction before dying of
an overdose but shutting down silk road
didn't make drugs less readily
available it only pushed sales onto less
trustworthy platforms
if the president does give ulbric
clemency much of the credit belongs to
his mother
lin who has spent the last five years
tirelessly advocating on his behalf
rehabilitation is done this is about
punishment
and making him an example ulbrich's
critics often point to a series of
contract killings that he allegedly
ordered with the intention of stopping
blackmailers who were threatening to
bring him down
but those allegations remain unproven
the alleged murders were never carried
out
and the government never charged him on
those counts
it's extremely irresponsible to
fall hard on one side or the other of
allegations involving murder
that have not been charged much less
proven perhaps the silk road's most
enduring legacy
is bootstrapping bitcoin as new york
times reporter nathaniel popper
explained
in 2015 silk road proved that bitcoin
worked
it proved that you could actually send
real value across the world
and people were willing to try that
experiment
because they had an incentive to because
getting heroin that way was that much
better than the alternative
freeing ross albrecht would be the most
appropriate way to cap off a year in
which american voters made it loud and
clear that they're ready to close the
book on the drug war
what frustrates me the most is you have
everyone out there
defending ross and um
and and i don't see anyone out there
defending all these poor people
who um who are in jail for selling
weed or magic mushrooms who are
african-american and hispanic if
ulbrich's supporters
really cared about the war on drugs or
libertarian ideals
built in a pine they'd be demanding that
the nearly half a million people
currently in u.s jails for drug offenses
should be pardoned too
and that's exactly what libertarians
have been saying going back to the 1970s
prior to his sentencing ross albrecht
wrote a letter to the judge
pleading for mercy i've had my youth and
i know you must take away my middle
years but please
leave me my old age i certainly won't be
the rebellious risk taker i was when i
created silk road in fact
i'll be an old man russell brick turned
36 this year
let's hope he's still a rebel and soon
enough once again
a free man